hallo
herzlich willkommen zur stylings welt
ich bin halt ein bisschen erkältet aber
ich glaube das hört man
ich habe ein motiv torte gebacken und
zwar zum thema james bond und daraus ist
diese torte entstanden meine freundin
sandra hat sich nämlich für ihren mann
diese torte gewünscht also normalerweise
mag ich ja keine auftrags torten aber
ich hab gedacht komme ich mal ein video
drüber und mache eine kleine freude und
habe deswegen gebacken
in dieser torte steckt unten eine
schokotorte mit schokoladen kenner und
oben eine torte mit ihm der buttercreme
und wir nicht sagt 'mensch mutter
buttercreme buttercreme mutter geht
wirklich auch buttercreme mag ich gar
nicht weg den unterschied zwischen
buttercreme und frucht buttercreme und
die ist wirklich sehr fruchtig in lecker
und ich benutzt ganz gerne butter krems
für motiv torten weise einfach sehr
stabil sind da ja auch viel dekoration
außen rum ist und ich kann eben gut dran
arbeiten
ich habe die torte jetzt die letzten
drei tage gebacken am ersten tag habe
ich die cremes und die tortenböden
gebacken
am zweiten tag habe ich so ein bisschen
deko vorbereitet und am dritten tag habe
ich die torte dann komplett
zusammengesetzt und wenn ihr euch das
immer zeitlich so ein bisschen ein teil
dann geht das ganze auch einfacher mag
an den rap den restlichen tag daneben
noch was anderes machen ja und nicht
dass leute überschuss drei volle tage
natürlich nicht alles ist möglich drei
tage dann immer nur kurz was gemacht und
da kann man sich das optimal einteilen
um die deko elemente können daneben gut
ausdrucken und jetzt zeige ich euch wenn
man die torte schritt für schritt macht
und startet direkt mit dem ersten tag
ich habe gestern schon einiges
vorbereitet und zwar habe ich die
tortenböden vorgebacken und die cremes
gemacht und zwar möchte ich eine
schokotorte unten und oben drauf eine
fruchtige himbeer torte
deswegen habe ich eine hinter graeme
vorbereitet habe zwei showbühnen
gebacken helle böden für oben und eine
zart peter karrasch und eine weiße
garage und ich werde die torte noch
füllen mit etwas marmelade also aprikose
und himbeere wir zwar nicht direkt mit
der hellen torte an
ich mag die böden immer lasse abkühlen
und dann denke ich sie ab und lasse bei
zimmertemperatur oder im kühlschrank
über nacht stehen
es braucht ihr zuerst eine tortenplatte
und zwar sollte die minimal größer sein
als die torte selber also die böden habe
ich jetzt 20 cm groß gebacken und die
platte ist daneben minimal größer so 45
mm 30 etwas ganz auf die untere platte
dann bleibt die torte schönen
draufkleben
und jetzt werden die tortenböden
einzelnen mit team der marmelade
bestrichen und mit der himba buttercreme
gefühl
die torte sitz gefüllt und kommen den
kühlschrank und in der zwischenzeit kann
ich auch die untere torte befüllen
ihr könnt die zwischenzeit während die
torte im kühlschrank ist immer wieder
nutzen und zum beispiel dekoelemente
herstellen die noch trocknen müssen
ich habe mir eine skizze gemacht und
jetzt möchte ich zu allererst mein
kickboard überziehen und zwar sollte so
ein roulette tisch werden und dafür
nehme ich jetzt von der in schwarz grün
und rot und kneten der erstmalig und
rollen hinaus
von dort lässt sich am besten auf etwas
becker stärker ausrollen
dies nämlich ganz fein und klub nicht
und dann klebt das ganze auch nicht
weder an der unterlage und auch nicht
auf dem ausbau statt
denn von dort sehe ich dann auf die
wakeboard platte und zwar hatte einen
durchmesser von 40 zentimetern
ich wollte gross genug machen das sich
heute gut drauf passt und dass ich sie
eben und schön dekorieren kann den
grünen teil muss ich jetzt aber gar
nicht so groß schneiden da reicht
nämlich einen kreis mit dem durchmesser
von 30 cm unter nämlich einfach eine
andere platte als schablone oder ihr
könnt auch einen deckel nehmen zb oder
einen teller
schwarz und rot brauche ich jetzt auch
ganz dünn ausgerollt und muss dann auch
so ein kreis schneiden mit 40
zentimetern durchmesser
roth habe ich bereits gemacht und was es
da hinten kurz antrocknen und schwarz
bereite ich jetzt genauso zu
die rote und schwarze platte sind jetzt
etwas an getrocknet und jetzt schneide
ich die felder für das roulette brett zu
dafür markiere ich jetzt erstmal den
mitte das mache ich jetzt einem jahr
und jetzt nehme ich einen torten
einteiler denn dass er schon die stücke
vor gekennzeichnet ich nehme jetzt alle
mit 18 stücken dann muss ich das jetzt
hier mittig platziert
so und kann jetzt mit dem lineal die
streichung wissen nach außen weiter
führen
jetzt nehme ich die platte die ich auch
für die grüne platte benutzt habe also
30 zentimeter platte und legt jetzt in
die mitte und schweizer am atom herum
und dann habe ich die einzelnen teile
und genau so mache ich das dann auch bei
rot und natürlich braucht ihr nur jedes
zweite
aber ich habe trotzdem alle zurecht
geschnitten denn dann suche ich mir
einfach die schönsten aus
die tortenplatte die bestreite ich jetzt
mit etwas essbarem kleber den tragische
großflächig auf und kann ihn dann mit
einem pinsel gut verstreichen
da auch darauf achten immer schön bis
zum rand den kader streichen
jetzt setzte außen schon mal ein rotes
feld an und kann dann nämlich direkt das
grüne feld in die mitte setzen jetzt
einfach mal gegenüber schauen ob es auch
passt ja das passt und jetzt nehme ich
immer die schönen uns jetzt rot und
schwarz direkt nebeneinander
so jetzt noch das letzte und diese
kleinen lücken zwischen durch die kann
man immer ganz gut mit dem von land
blätter einfach ein bisschen ausbessern
und in fawn dann immer so aneinander
schieben
und jetzt muss ich da außen nur noch den
rand wegschneiden
jetzt nehme ich noch mal etwas weißer
modelliermasse also von dort mit etwas
cmc pulver vermischt und bestreut es mit
etwas zucker stärke und rollt es ist
erst mal dünn aus und zwar möchte ich
hier noch ein paar pokerkarten machen
und habe hier auch ein paar schablonen
bereits ausgedruckt also in etwa sollen
die dann aussehen und deswegen muss ich
die platte erst mal ganz schön aus
rollen was mache ich jetzt heute schon
und das ist dann bis morgen trocknen und
kann er morgen daran weiterarbeiten
und jetzt schneide ich diesen streifen
zurecht und zwar möchte diese karten
ausschneiden und nehmen dafür jetzt hier
so ein riesiges fahrrad und kann das
schön einteilen damit kann man auch
immer teig streifen ganz genau
zurechtschneiden immer mit dem gleichen
abstand
jetzt muss ich immer noch hier ein
durchschreiten
und die ecken runde ich jetzt mit einem
kater ab
und aus dem restlichen weiß ich jetzt
noch zahlen aus und zwar wird das
geburtstagskind 40 deswegen 0 0 und das
ganze 18 mal in das kommt dann noch auf
den roulette tisch
jetzt habe ich hier schwarze modell a
device geknetet und rollen sie auf 5 mm
stärke aus und daraus mache ich dann so
ein paar goldene münzen und dann stand
sich dann noch den namen vom
geburtstagskind ein
und dafür habe ich hier diese träge
buchstaben die pflege ich jetzt erstmal
ein und mit zwei hunden ausstellern
werde ich jetzt noch die münze
ausstechen den kleineren lege ich direkt
um den namen herum und tourismus so ein
bisschen einstampfen und mit dem
größeren stand sich dann das ganze aus
jetzt könnte man hier noch was einprägen
ich habe es keine sterne und nehme jetzt
hier diesem lebensmittel farbstift und
benutzt den deckel und stehe ich jetzt
einfach mehrere davon aus
die torte jetzt komplett eingedeckt und
jetzt zeige ich euch wie man dieses gold
pulver auf die torte bringt man kann das
gold pulver entweder trocken auf inseln
dann hat man nur so einen leichten gold
effekt oder man nimmt ein küchentuch und
befeuchtet es ganz leicht aber wirklich
nur ganz leichter von dort auf jetzt
wirklich nicht zu nass werden und dann
wird die torte ein bisschen befeuchtet
das mache ich jetzt immer stellenweise
und bremste dann darüber und dafür könnt
ihr ganz normale pinsel nehmen am besten
eignet sich zum beispiel auch kosmetik
pinsel
die sollen natürlich sauber sein
beim auftragen könnt ihr gerne mehrere
schichten auftragen also mehrere gold
puder schichten
ich habe gestern für die torte alles
vorbereitet das heißt hier diese
skateboard überzogen habt diese goldenen
münzen vorbereitet und habe sogar beide
torten schon mit von dort bezogen
diese smoking torte die komplette
anleitung findet ihr in einem separaten
video wo die untere torte habe ich mit
gold eingekleidet also mit so einem
apricot stone und hab dann mit gold
fuder das ganze bepinselt die videos
dazu verlinkt ich alle natürlich in der
infobox
jetzt muss ich die torte nur noch fertig
stellen und zwar habe ich ja die karten
bereits vorbereitet dass alle gut
durchgetrocknet und ich habe ich bereits
eine vorgewarnt die schablonen habe ich
mit ausgedruckt und kann direkt drauf
legen oder bis hier etwas verpasste in
schwarz etwas verdünnt mit alkohol
ihr könnt aber zum beispiel auch palm
ihn benutzen als und kokosfett normal
ich einmal so grob die linien aus
währung
trotz ein paar anhaltspunkte
jetzt kann ich mit einem pinsel alles
fein ausmachen
jetzt muss ich nur noch diese märkte in
goldbeck rudern
das geht einfach so ganz trocken
jetzt bin ich fertig und kann die torte
zusammensetzen und damit die torte auf
dem kick bottles nicht verrutscht
streiche ich da ein bisschen kanal
schmitten rein da kommt jetzt die
goldene torte mit ich drauf
und jetzt möchte ich die obere tor drauf
setzen aber weil das gewicht von dieser
torte dann in die untere einzigen würde
muss ich die torte jetzt noch
stabilisieren und zwar nämlich dafür
jetzt cake pops ticks und steckte hier
erst mal ein paket der damals doch bis
hin zu kurz ich muss längere nehmen und
stehe muss ich jetzt noch zurecht
schneiden
ich setze jetzt die zweite tochter oben
drauf und ich klebte jetzt aber noch
nicht fest denn ich möchte später im
kühlschrank noch separat la kann bis
morgen
aber wenn er sie jetzt direkt serviert
könnte ich auch direkt aufeinander
stapeln und natürlich auch mit ghanas
ankleben
die torte sitzt fertig und beim motiv
mache ich immer ganz gerne so dass ich
mich vorher eine zeichnung mache und
dann weiß ich nämlich immer was auf mich
zukommt und was ich eben alles erledigen
muss die torte ist fertig die sand ragen
morgen früh ab nein moratti toto wird
nicht probiert warum steckt man jetzt
ganz schnell da die keiner heute leider
nicht probiert noch nicht anschneiden
denn das ist eine geburtstagstorte da
geht mir wirklich eine münster bestand
nicht eingeladen dann gebe ich eine
münze für münzen eine gold lisa kohler
hier
ich habe jetzt die gegeben wo ich die
markierung vergessen habe
wer kommt schmeckt wurde hier schokolade
einmal schokolade rallye was ich so
mache nichts falls ihr diese torte nach
machen wollte und nach machen werdet
dann freue ich mich natürlich wenn er
mir ein paar fotos schickt auf facebook
oder instagram und mich darauf verlinkt
also ich finde die torte ist
handwerklich nicht schwer aber nicht
schwierig aber man braucht halt ein
bisschen zeit bisschen geduld und ja
spaß wochen auch bis nach essen habe ich
immer dabei also ich wünsche euch ganz
viel spaß beim nachbacken und wissens
das nächste mal wieder biss dann fürs
und falls ihr motiv torten vorschläge
habt dann immer her damit kann die karte
essen 3